il ya plein de peintres hyper
intéressante à dire parce que
effectivement semi 9
il ya déjà des choses qui ont annoncé de
façon officielle des photos qui ont été
montrées me parle
[Musique]
regardez ce que j'ai ramené du cfa déjà
il ya quelques temps
jamais un petit panneau que j'ai
récupéré à la fin sur le stand de la
punchline on n'est pas je sais pas trop
où j'allais de m je trouve une place
dans studio on va voir ça si vous avez
une idée vous pouvez me dire à mon
commentaire
ça me dérange pas aujourd'hui parlons
peu parlons bien on va parler
aujourd'hui du futur shiomi neuf qui va
être présenté le 20 sept le 20 septembre
pourquoi le 20 septembre qui va être
présenté à l'intégrer y ait en chine
si vous êtes concentré et si vous suivez
le 20 ou le 20 février c'est une journée
qui vous aura pas échappé pas que le 20
février
samsung va présenter ses futurs samsung
galaxy s 10 ainsi que son smartphone à
écran pliable autant dire que le 20
février ça c'est beaucoup de choses
et au final c'est assez stratégique
parce que samsung va faire sa
présentation heure française à 17h 18h
un peu plus tôt forcément parce que la
présentation se fait depuis san
francisco alors que la chine va la faire
beaucoup plus tôt comme ça les chinois
auront la primeur de l'annoncé
au niveau du smartphone shiomi a donc
présenté son nouveau smartphone avec un
qualcomm snapdragon 855 bien avant que
samsung présente son smartphone avec un
sa dragonne 855 donc pendant quelques
heures
chiots mistral seul à avoir présenté un
smartphone intégrant un qualcomm
snapdragon 855 voilà pour la petite info
alors il ya plein de trucs hyper
intéressante à dire parce que
effectivement semi 9
il ya déjà des choses qui ont été
annoncées de façon officielle des photos
qui ont été montrés par li jun qui est
le big boss de shiomi
donc ça c'est intéressant on va donc
regarder dans un premier temps à quels
sont ces infos officielles qu'est ce
qu'on a sur ce smartphone deuxièmement
on va regarder les fuites et les rumeurs
parce qu'à des choses qui sont vraiment
tangible qui ont chuté et puis troisième
point on va voir au final une fois qu'on
a un peu ce portrait robot de
smartphones qu'est ce qu'on peut en
faire qu est-ce qui va nous apporter
comme usage acquise des styles 1 qu ici
accompagné si ça donc ça c'est cool
première chose
j'aime tellement cette petite lampe
cactus que m'a offert mon fils que je
suis obligé de la bête de groupe ça
c'est cool alors il y a des photos qui
ont été publiées par lee jones hugo son
compte weibo webo qui est un réseau
social chinois si toutefois je ne suis
pas votre truc je peux comprendre vous
connaissez pas forcément
alors si c'est ce qu'on voit sur ces
photos on voit que la face arrière et 11
usines les morts et le bas du smartphone
sur la face arrière on voit un triple
module photo ça c'est assez intéressant
parce qu'on voit qu'effectivement les
constructeurs vont toujours plus loin en
termes de photos vidéos mais surtout au
niveau de la photo on voit également
qu'il n'ya pas de capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos âgées vous expliquer où
devrait situer le capteur d'empreintes
digitales donc 1,2 au final assez clean
et en plus sur la photo est ce qui est
super intéressant il ya une photo il y
aussi une vidéo on voit un dégradé de
bleu un peu vert violi très sympa très
jolie indo qui franchement bien réussi
très très maîtrisée sur le bar on voit
une prise en usb tilt c'est une petite
grille donc à mon avis il y aura une
pour le micro et une pour un haut
parleur à savoir si le haut parleur on
pourra de notre côté ça vire à un peu de
renfort ou si on aura uniquement du son
mono ça on le verra bien évidemment plus
tard on voit également sur la tranche 1
10 ans pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
bouton volume et sur l'autre côté sur
l'autre tranche un autre but ont assez
intéressant qu'on peut imaginer
complètement être un bouton dédié à
l'intelligence artificielle à google à 6
ans ça s'appelle coule donc vendre un
peu les infos qu'on a aujourd'hui
de ce point de vue là il ya une autre
personne haut placée chez chuo milk
publié des photos prises avec le mineur
les photos officielles et il ya marqué
dessus sur iphoto 40 8 mégapixels et ça
c'est très intéressant parce que
aujourd'hui le seul appareil photo 48
mégapixels c'est celui qui était
présenté sur le au nord view vin c'est
le sony mx 5 186 alors je sais pas si
vous avez vu ma vidéo sur les honneurs
view vin c'est pas le cas elle doit
s'afficher quelque part par ici je vous
invite à aller la voir et ils ont fait
un test photo vidéo également avec cet
appareil photo desaulniers mx 5 186 vous
permet d'avoir d'excellents détail au
niveau des photos vous permettra d'avoir
un système de faux
nuit c'est à dire quatre pick salle en
un donc en gros vous avez utilisé quatre
gros pixels jeu les transformer en un
seul gros pixels donc pour des photos
nues ça vous fera de belles photo 12
mégapixels
donc c'est un appareil photo qui va être
très bien pour pouvoir aller un petit
peu zoomer dans l'image pour récupérer
du détail pour la photo nue c'est hyper
optimisé pour avoir un appareil hyper
cool ce sony mx 5 186 et bien et il
devrait donc équipé ce nouveau
smartphone alors il reste deux autres
appareils photo et ça je vous en
parlerai dans la partie un peu plus
rumeurs parce que là dessus pour
l'instant il n'y a rien d'officiel on a
également une autre photo qui était
présente et où on voit dans une autre
couleur
peut-être un peu plus girly si je suis
un peu les grands stéréotypes avec un
rose dégradé violine bleus qui
franchement c'est très sympa
une autre info publié également si on a
beau se rend compte de ligne jaune c'est
qu'il va intégrer le snapdragon 1855 est
donc le socle plus haut de gamme
actuellement chez qualcomm très
intéressant parce que on voit qu'à terme
d'empreinte digitale au dos donc à un
moment ou un autre on va déverrouiller
d'une manière ou d'une autre combat dit
oui façon sécurisée de ce qu'on voit en
tout cas des images il n'y a pas de
capteur d'empreintes digitales sur la
tranche je ne pense pas qu'ils intègrent
une techno équivalente à ce que pourrait
proposer apple avec sa caméra 3
dimensions donc tout porte à croire
qu'on va retrouver un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée sous
l'écran est ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que justement ce snapdragon 855
supporte le capteur empreintes digitales
à ultrasons intégré à l'écran alors ce
capteur d'empreintes est vachement
intéressant parce qu'il est beaucoup
plus rapide que ce qu'on peut retrouver
notamment sur le wan pu assister et sur
le au pot elle existait des pros donc on
devrait déverrouiller très rapidement de
façon très sécurisée
ça c'est pour la partie annonce
officielle maintenant je vais vous dire
un petit peu quelles sont les tendances
les fuites les rumeurs par rapport
justement à ce bilan il y à des fuites
s'il ya des photos qui ont été présentés
et il ya un descriptif ça c'est
intéressant
alors ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on devrait
avoir un grand écran avec une diagonale
de 6,5 pouces un écran amoled avec un
ratio 19/9 et une résolution fhd plus on
devient trouver sur l'écran en une
petite encoche en goudeau comme ce qu'on
retrouve sur le wan fussistes et des
bords très fin sur le côté et un tout
petit menton donc un écran qui
occuperait la majeure partie la phase
avant je vous parlais du sein dragon 855
qui devrait être couplé à 6 giga de ram
on peut très bien imaginer sa part chuté
mais pourquoi pas une version un peu
plus premium un peu plus boosté avec 8
gigas de ram
andré avoir en termes de stockage 128
giga de stockage je vous parle donc de
l'appareil photo avec un capteur
principal des 48 mégapixels
on devrait avoir un capteur secondaire
de 12 mégapixels ainsi qu'une caméra
tough alors tough si ça vous parle pas
c'est ce qu'on appelle la caméra time of
light
en gros c'est un capteur en trois
dimensions qui va être capable de
modéliser ce qui va voir devant lui donc
de se rendre compte des volumes et de la
veille avoir pleins d'applications
possibles des applications sur les jeux
vidéo parce qu'il va pouvoir comprendre
des mouvements donc pouvoir
l'interpréter pour de jeux vidéo donc ça
peut être assez rigolo ça on l'a vu
notamment sur le ono review 20 il ya un
petit bloc avec qu'on peut avoir pour
l'utiliser pour différents jeux ça peut
être très rigolo on peut aussi la voir
par exemple pour du comptage de calories
ce qu'on a sur les honneurs vu 20 vous
avez un muffin dans la main vous le
montrer à l'appareil
il reconnaît le volume et de la qui peut
vous comptez sensiblement les calories
par rapport au volume alors c'est à
saint parfait mais en tout cas c'est
pourquoi pas assez intéressant ce triple
capteurs on aurait donc une caméra 48
mégapixels une 12 mégapixels et une
caméra tough tout ça devrait tourner sur
android 9 paille avec la surcouche iwai
on aurait une batterie de 3500 millan
terreur de la recharge rapide 32 watt de
la recharge très rapide et de la coupe
charles 4.0
le technique pour le technique c'est
intéressant maintenant la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire avec ce
smartphone qu'est-ce qu'il peut vous
apporter du coup à qui il est destiné
alors il ya plusieurs choses déjà le
fait d'abord un grand écran 6 24 pouces
amoled
on voit qu'on est très clairement sur un
smartphone qui est fait pour le
multimédia visionnage de vidéos réseaux
sociaux et jeux vidéo jeux vidéo en plus
par extension avec le stand dragon 855
de la performance si giga de ram de la
fluidité du stockage avec à 128 giga de
ram donc un smartphone qui est fait pour
regarder vos vidéos et donc pour pouvoir
s'amuser un côté un peu ludique avec
l'appareil photo le 48 mégapixels des
photos complètement super optimisé pour
le partage sur les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est un smartphone qui s'adresse
forcément un public assez large
on peut imaginer un public un peu plus
jeune pour le côté jeu vidéo multimédia
le côté multimédia vous l'attendez au
travers désastre aujourd'hui on regarde
tous du contenu multimédia et on est
tous sur les réseaux sociaux pas tous
quasiment tous en tout cas en majeure
partie et la photo parce qu'aujourd'hui
on prend tous des photos qu'on partage
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'au final
c'est un smartphone assez
intergénérationnel avec de la
performance avec de la puissance avec de
la fluidité avec une batterie qui me
paraît être assez intéressante même si
en termes de chiffres 3500 milliampères
heures si c'est avéré c'est parce
qu'être plus de dingue mais ça optimisé
avec larissa dragon 855 ça va vraiment
devenir optimiser l'utilisation de votre
batterie et l'autonomie globale de votre
machine dont quelque chose d'optimiser
puis surtout il nous laissera jamais
tomber avec une recharge rapide 32 watts
vous le branchez en dix minutes pour
partez vous êtes vraiment tranquille
donc on devrait avoir aussi une
excellente autonomie
alors je vous le disais c'est un
smartphone qui va être présenté dans
quelques jours le 20 février en chine
on va être amené à en reparler ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais aller au mwc elle
d'ici quelques jours à barcelone je sais
pas si on pourra le retrouver
ça serait bien en tout cas permettre un
peu de le prendre en main il y aura la
course de chiens ont mis quelques jours
plus tard à barcelone donc je vous en
dirai plus je vous invite à vous abonner
comme ça vous aurez accès à toutes les
infos je serai de mon côté mois le 20
février à londres pour aller voir les
nouveaux smartphones de samsung sap est
aussi très
intéressant je vous invite à me dire ce
que vous en pensez vous de ce 1900 bas
en commentaire je sais que sioniste est
une marque qui cartonne de plus en plus
en europe qui s'installe et début 2018
qui arrivait à barcelone justement pour
le mwc qui arrivaient plus tard en
france qui développe de plus en plus
qu'on va retrouver de plus en plus en
europe qui devrait aussi aller sur le
continent américain
donc c'est vraiment hyper hyper
intéressant et c'est une marque une très
belle croissance et qui montre en tout
cas cette vraie attractivité cette
montée en puissance des marques
chinoises comme notamment one plus au
nord huawei xiaomi au pot et plein
d'autres donc ça c'est très très très
intéressant dont je vous invite à me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas et je
vous invite également à consulter ma
playlist pour connaître toutes les infos
sur les smartphones qui vont sortir en
2019 et vous allez voir il y en a plein
c'est très intéressant d'ici là soyez
sages non je vous embrasse vous envoie
de l'amour des bijoux qui vous envoie
tout ça à bientôt ciao